look who's coming in Ice Cube what's
going on man all right which welcome
welcome to the show right Sam Roberts is
Mike Cannon I don't know how your new
movie fist fight it's coming out of you
have you seen it yeah you have to is
that the choreography of that fight
scene for you yes has to be so important
because like if Ice Cube doesn't look
like a [ __ ] bad-ass
even though it's a comedy movie you're
in trouble right in a way I'm writing a
teacher so I mean you don't expect too
much from me I'll have to look like a
seal I mean or crack maybe no no you
know so uh he's a teacher but but he has
a shady past nobody know what he did you
know was he was he in the CIA you know
was he part of the Mexican drug cartel I
mean nobody knows what would would uh
Dixon did that's not a Dixon this time
it's trickling stream I'm getting caught
up with characters yeah so this is was
just one of were you involved in this
movie more than just acting or read you
strictly acting in this movie
um I'm executive producer okay no but
but you know I didn't do the heavy
lifting on this movie it was brought to
us by by Richard King and Charlie Day
who they've done things on Always Sunny
um and he's directed some of those
episodes and this was his first feature
and when he showed me the kind of movie
he wanted to make I was all in
yeah a wild right I mean this entire
season I've always Sonny it's their 12th
and they're still so prolific and so
edgy they really like they go after it
man yeah which is great you know that's
what you want you know in TV you want
people who are not not afraid to uh to
you know go for it and you know you
don't want people to hold their self
back do you like doing that because
you've done so many projects where like
you'll take the reins on kind of
everything you know that means yeah that
is it nice to be able to just go be an
executive producer but pretty much just
act and you're kind of done pretty much
you know um you know I was a little more
hands-on with this just a little dinner
you know that because this is Ritchie's
first time as a director so you gotta
gotta be there for him you know because
did you ever think that happened in your
life that you'd be the guy on the set
telling the director like no this is how
the business works kid I never thought
that that's where we are you know uh you
know everybody looked at me like Q
you've done more movies than all of us
is it right or not so yeah so it's cool
to be in that position to be able to
influence the movie and not just act and
you know when you just act sometimes you
can see the train go off the tracks and
you can't do nothing about it but sit
there you know but you know when you're
a producer you can get in there say what
the hell is going on in here what what's
going on right right especially when
that word executive is in front of the
producer yeah that's when you can really
say what the hell's going without a
doubt we have it down so the jeweler's
spa are you uh do you like do you need
that kind of control on the stuff that
you're doing like I would imagine like
even early on like when you make that
move to leave NWA which is massive I
mean you know what I mean that you
didn't have anything in the bag waiting
for you like I'm just kind of relied on
yourself after that once that's
successful what's your solo rap career
is successful at that point do you go
without like gonna do anything unless
like I can have control this is way
better not really you know I'm not a god
who has to take control is usually for
quality control yeah that's really what
it's all about it's not like I need to
do everything for it to turn out right
because I don't I don't believe that I
think it's smart people all around and
you just uh you just kind of let them
know your vision and then you let them
do what they do best and you supervise
them you know what they're doing and
make sure it coincide with what you want
to do so great that's really what it's
all about you know I'm not a control
freak unless I'm not controlling it
that's the only time anything good gets
made is when you actually trust your
collaborators right because otherwise
you're just you're micromanaging and if
you try to control their vision on top
of yours and it can all get muddled and
[ __ ] up it's terrible it's terrible
when you have a director running around
like a chicken with his head cut off
because he's trying to do everybody job
yeah yeah you have qualified people
they're saying
you hired me to do this let me do it and
so I'm not into that I'm into letting
people shine letting people do what they
do best even actors you know I'm not
like oh man he's gonna stick you don't
steal this scene by me how do i how do I
make sure that don't happen okay so I
just it's all about a collaborative
effort sometimes you got to toss the
Elliot now you don't get without a doubt
especially with movies cute got over a
hundred people that's really working to
make this thing happen now with a record
I'm a little different because I can go
in there and do it myself
really um yeah so it's a little
different but the movies you got it you
got it
gotta have a team I was thinking about
that like do you think are you putting
out another album yes is it more
difficult now do you think like you
could have written the lyrics that you
wrote on your first solo album because
there were some like raunchy not even
raunchy but just like hardcore [ __ ] raw
raw is the word and I swear a lot more
politically correct now yet the society
than we were when like no Vaseline came
out yeah you know what I mean like I
don't think like even though the context
is no Vaseline he's like whoa but we
don't forget a little homophobic that he
said you know I mean there's there's so
many little things that you have to
dance around that we did you got good
you know what and everything this seemed
like wasn't entertainment better like in
the 70s late 80s where you know
everything was a little raw it was all
washed down and cleaned up and you know
like put a fluffy bow on everything and
so you know me I'm all about being real
so I feel like I could still write those
lyrics and I could take the heat that
comes after that you know my new record
is called everything's corrupt it'll be
out soon as I finish it because I've
been doing movies and you know it's been
kind of getting pushed back so you know
I'm really all about being provocative
man that's what isn't that's what a
rapper should be here and it shouldn't
be a politically correct rapper that
just sounds like an oxymoron yeah and
also the PC culture kind of almost
doesn't go
to hip-hop all the time because they
feel such like white guilt that they
won't pretend they like or you cannot
say that they're like well you know
speak on your experience they don't want
to like well I don't because I don't
know if I point out that he said
something offensive am I being racist
right I want to I don't want to say that
and if you get away with more it's crazy
how fear is is like a driving force in
us being so ignorant and running into
each other all the time yes and being so
uncomfortable all the time because of
these like fears that you have in the
back of your head that really don't
matter at the time or the race most of
the time and it stops people from being
creative right like it's because you're
sitting there if you're thinking about
how is this going to be perceived what
type of feedback am I going to get from
this what then you're not that's not art
yeah you're not doing it yeah that's
trying to package you know that's that's
probably just trying to shove a present
down somebody's throat like I made this
cookie eat it yeah no I'm saying instead
of just saying hey cookies are there you
like them a night yeah that's what
artists are supposed to be here it is
you like it or not I don't care I'm
alright to the next thing realm it's
probably similar about like trying to
control everything on a movie set you're
just you know all things go hey why are
people that are so caught up in like
words and how to frame certain ideas are
losing out on the actual [ __ ]
conversation because all they're doing
is combing through every single word
that they're using as opposed to paying
attention to the actual message without
a doubt yeah when I would down yeah
were you happy with the way your son
portrayed you in Straight Outta Compton
oh yeah man he did a spine yeah I was
too you had to good my gosh if I asked
you to my it means just as much yeah he
was a it was awesome man I know he was
the right dude for the job when I looked
at him one day and I'm saying like I'm
taking him on tour with me and stuff
with doing shows he's out there he's
ferocious on the mic yeah I mean he's
reminded me of a young me I'm like man
what the goodness Kid Act will he take
it serious because I mean he's had a
great life to be
you know he's yeah buddy can do is have
fun and spend my money so I wonder did
he you know what he gets serious enough
in something that he is not you know
pursuing right my dream right will you
get serious enough to do this and he was
like yeah I'm knocking out the box he
said as a matter of fact I can't see
nobody else in the world doing it so he
almost got competitive with it like
that's my that's my role yep yeah and I
told him I said you know it's gonna be
obstacles because I couldn't give him
the job I write and say this is yours I
had to first okay with the director Gary
gray because when I first told him that
I'm thinking about putting my son in it
he was like what kind of movie we trying
to make which one makes real [ __ ] me
want you I said look dude I know he can
do it I said I wasn't acting when I did
boys in the hood somebody gave me a shot
right I said Gary I gave you a shot when
you directed Friday you had never
directed a movie mm-hmm give my son a
shot at it he's he can audition like
everybody else so he he passed Gary's
test then he had to go in front of the
brass at Universal and his screen test
was through the roof yeah and and he got
the part because that's a big deal
because you're right it's not like
they're putting together one of these
like made-for-tv like B et here's the
real story behind where it's kind of
like schlock it's like we're actually
going for for real movie we're going for
theatrical where where you're for a real
movie yeah and you know um so and I
wouldn't had it no no other way I mean
being in control of the project you know
me dr. Dre eazy-e a state ran yella
no way in the world we have control of
this project and let them just provide
some you know fluffy little character of
what it was well that was amazing also
about considering how your son was
brought up and you know the privilege he
was able to access that type of grit and
raw from your past was there anything
that you kind of
pressed upon him to get that type of
performance or was that just something
he picked up from watching it well I
mean I'm pretty sure he picked it up
because you know he has lived a
privileged life you know but but I keep
real people around me you know I didn't
live a pretty privileged life I can't
even say it
no I didn't do it so um so I still keep
real people from from my old
neighborhood around the ones that got
sense of course and and he's been around
you know he's been around as a dog that
life he just haven't been in the hood
yeah all his line right he was able to
you know hone that and I would tell him
you know what I was filling this day you
know what I was thinking to Dre that day
what I thought it easy what I thought so
he had so much information to kind of as
ammunition if he ever you know felt the
silver I lost God is that it was that
tough for you even raising him like
trying to figure out how do I instill
stuff that was instilled in me having
him live a completely opposite
experience no I you know I growing up in
the hood is nothing to brag about you
know I'm saying is not easy it's not
hard most people would rather grow up in
a entertainer environment right I'm
saying so I'm glad and I'm lucky that my
kids and have to go through the stuff I
had to go through when it come to gangs
and you know doping in the police and
just being broke and so you know I feel
lucky and blessed and I'm happy I you
know I don't want them to ever have to
experience that kind of stuff did you
really smash up that executives record
or the record executives office yeah
don't feel good about that good about
that I do you know I mean I try not to
be a violent person and Friday second
car he just pushed me to the limit and
here's why you know um I had sold a lot
of Records with America's Most Wanted
and I think kill at will and I wanted an
advancement on my next record because
O'Shea jr. was about to be born
okay hey there so I say man you know I
got a baby coming and I need to get out
of this apartment that I was in I want
to get a house for my family by the way
that's crazy when you talk about like -
like elastic albums right yeah and
they're out and they've sold and like
it's not like people found them later
like those were giant albums yes and
you're like I'm gonna try to get out of
an apartment now I mean I was in the
apartment cuz I that was really my first
time being able to move out and do
anything so that was just my spot
I was stacking money then but I was 100
grand short on this house uh-huh because
when you buy a house you gotta have not
only your money but a little extra money
to give away for the house so I was 100
grand short I said dude I need
advancement on my record you know I mean
give me advancement and uh you know the
album almost finished he was like cool
you know on the phone he's like cool so
when we went through escrow I called him
my yellow escrow about the clothes I'm a
hundred G's short I need that too I
don't know what um ah
what I don't never saying I would give
you that I was like dude don't play with
me come on yeah I don't remember giving
you that I said oh okay
I saw them on my way up there terrible
news yeah and uh I got up there and you
know I walked through they they saw me
with a bat so cute a man calling a paper
animals Club just coming to get this
style
so we're Brian a man so I go in his
office now I got the lynch mob with me
you know I got right you know JD
t-bone shorty we go in there and he's in
his bathroom in his office and uh and so
we you know of course in the movie we
walk in and it just happens cherish it
but in reality he was in the bathroom
and when he came out
you just posted up in his office by the
way for fire fire I know that's the only
reason he didn't shoot himself
yeah come out of it a half room
otherwise hello hey thank you
what's up what's going on like he didn't
know yeah like so he goes his desk and I
go and close the door one of those now
you can't leave and uh and I just
started berating man and telling why
he's long and [ __ ] up for what he's
doing and I just got more heated and
heated and heated and then I was looking
at all these records and everything had
I was so fed up at this time with with
this paper-pushing called a lawyer all
this kind of this was the world I didn't
know right so I'm like now I gotta take
this back to South Central if I said
rearrange his office point and uh and
what they say when you're smashing all
of his [ __ ] is he like this is the way
to just come on do what the TV come on
talking about companies we break out and
the whole office is like what the hell
just happened now everybody looking at
us walk through we get on the elevator
we go down and it's like LAPD everywhere
freeze all this up against the wall we
up against the wall and and the the
other owner mark ceramic comes down he's
like kill what happened what's going on
I'm like man Brian he's messed up
boom boom are telling me said man no
charge can you guys just leave him alone
we don't want to charge no charge us or
the police backed up he's a kid call me
tomorrow man please I called him he
wrote me to check for 100 G's I got my
house yeah I said junior didn't have to
grow up homeless and all these I think
it yeah yeah we made up six months later
uh-huh you know and when I went back up
there though they have bulletproof glass
I got chaos
bulletproof glass this thick you have to
get buzzed in get you and walk you back
and all this kind of stuff it was crazy
I know Sporting Goods either that's
exactly what every Kennedy Fried Chicken
on my neighborhood houses yeah
absolutely proof glass yeah so do you is
that make it more difficult like what's
once you're like oh this work are you
isn't that difficult to not realize that
wait I have this in my back pocket I
could do business this way nah not only
want to go that route yeah I felt like
people lose too many people already
scared of me so this just didn't help
business at all you know it kind of you
know made people kind of leery for a
while oh I'm really I didn't dig that
because I felt like I'm not in it for
that I'm in it to make good records make
good music and keep it moving at what
point did you like think yourself I want
to make like a family movie I don't want
to be scary IceCube all the time I want
to be a dad you know Emily movie well
you know what the trip is we used to
watch stuff like home alone on the bus
individuate went home alone and all
these crazy uh movies you know coming to
America and I love Hollywood shuffle so
you never inspired you a song about the
Wet Bandits oh no no I love the idea of
passing blunts around the bus and
watching Kevin McCallister zany antics
yeah it was so fun but but so we was you
know hip to all kind of movies growing
up and having fun with it and when I got
to a certain point I start seeing that
my fans had kids and you would have the
father saying this is Ice Cube
he's famous he raps and he has to teach
his kids who I am and I'm like whoa
that's no good kids need to know
oh that's when I decided I need to do
something because kids shouldn't be
going to see the Friday movies and you
know these hard movies they should
actually have something for them yeah so
I say y'all are we there yet is the
movie because of my kids fans and now
I'm cool with that that generation now
they're 10
they're gonna go see fistfight because
they love me and are we there yet
well friend loyalty that's what it's all
about we're all about grabbing the next
generation so in a few years I'm going
to do another kids movie but that's
these but that's so smart because a lot
of people have this ego about them where
you think because you came out with a
couple of albums however many years ago
that should just last for a lifetime so
what the [ __ ] you mean your kids don't
know who I am you know what albums I put
out and they're like 25 years ago right
yeah you got to keep going I keep it
moving and moving and grabbing the new
generation who who had different rappers
that they were into you know so with the
movies it's a great way to to have fans
from eight to 80 and crippled and crazy
when you're when you're putting it when
you're working on new music do you have
to like stop yourself from being
influenced by music that's out right now
like you know or you mumble rapping
through songs nah I'm not I'm not really
when I when I go to make a record or
when I start and I'm think okay here's
Tommy get in the studio I try not to
listen to anything mm-hmm
just so I can make sure I'm having pure
you know thoughts and that I'm doing it
my way
because that's why you buy records
because this person has his own style
and I like it right and this person has
his own style and I like it and if you
start like bleeding into other people's
Lane then you don't become unique and
and artists who've been in it for as
long as I've been in it has to maintain
their sound
they can't go chasing sound right after
maintaining all sound because that's
what the fans like from them
well that might like it now considering
the social and political climate of
things do you find it are you circling
back and touching on some of the things
that you did touch on with NWA and with
the America's Most Wanted like is it
similarly that's a question like which
side which side does Donald Trump hit
for you is it the millionaire side where
you're like yeah he's a businessman I'm
about business too or is it this
rebellious political dude rebellious
political dude
yeah because as a millionaire he can be
he can be as crazy as he want to be on
his own dime you know me
now he's crazy representing all of us
right so some of the stuff he do is not
cool period it's just not presidential
right yeah so if I if there's ever a
White House Tour and Ice Cube shows up
with a baseball bat on the - ha ha ha
somebody better be alerted IQ will never
show up to the White House baseball IQ
will never probably show up to the White
House a nice healthy distance yes yes
yes it makes sense what about Friday are
you going to do you know I guess you get
asked I feel like every time you do
anything but it is the Friday franchise
going to live on or is that done I hope
so
you know we want to do another one but
we got to do it right yeah it looks like
we can do it we could've did it years
ago but it would have been wrong and
it's like you don't do it if it can't be
right I'm not touching it so it looks
like things and I've been saying this
the same like for five years but it
looks like things are moving in the
right direction when did you get like
comfortable with that air because like
movies are like that like movies and I
guess music maybe a little bit but at
least like you said with music you can
get into a studio you can record a song
like it speaks for itself like movies
take forever to be made yes and you got
to have a you know a consensus yeah on
what it should be with them with the
studio with the executives you know with
the producers with the directors with
the actors and it got to work for the
fans so it's a lot of people a lot of
cooks in the kitchen and all of them
have say in a way yeah yeah yeah how
long did it take for you to get like
acclimated to the process of like no
this is going to take a while but once
it gets done it'll it'll be good once I
took a movie to the 11th hour
you know we had everything set up and
they pushed it back yeah and we ended up
never doing that movie honest so I
realized that you can always be in
development hell and things just take as
long as they take right along set for
ten years Wow ten years at another
studio but you gotta be glad you guys
sometimes that's a good thing because
you wouldn't gotten Kevin Hart ten years
ago yeah man you know you know I mean
coming off a soul plane he would have
been perfect
yeah actually that's listen everybody
goes through fistfight it's in theaters
February 17th if you want to see Ice
Cube be a badass and beat up Charlie Day
that's the movie are you sure that I get
Charlie Day I lied I want to spoil it
okay I don't want to spoil don't be too
sure now I don't think you know now come
with this fight yeah all right man thank
you for coming by